hi my name is Matt I'm gonna show you
how to run all the Vulcan samples in
Vulcan demos from Nvidia this is on
Windows and this is also just using the
latest version of Vulcan stuff as of
today and the repos as of today I'm
going to start from the very beginning
and go all the way to the end where you
can run everything first part I'm going
to show you how to get everything set up
some prereqs
fork is optional you basically want
something with get makes it easy so this
is the setup I'm using I'm using an
Nvidia graphics card so that's why I'm
looking at all the Nvidia stuff you're
using a and an AMD graphics card or an
Intel graphics card what's gonna happen
but you'll have different drivers but
everything else might be the same or
might be very close these are
specifically Nvidia samples from Nvidia
design works so if you have a newer and
video card with the latest drivers which
if you're a normal human you do you
probably already have this Vulcan driver
support ready to go but in case you
don't you can go here and download it
okay
and the Vulcan SDK one of the core
things you're gonna need is this
software developer toolkit the Vulcan
SDK and you can get that right here at
so you want this you want to go to
probably this website and we just search
bulk and SDK you'll get some links but
basically what you're looking for is the
latest Windows installer and the last
thing is we need all these samples where
we're gonna get the code from and run
and you get these from github comm /nv
Pro samples okay so now we're going to
go on to the second phase where we
actually start to get this together and
we run it
so all the pre setup is assumed done
assume you've installed all that
software so we're just gonna leave this
off to the side for a second and we're
gonna first of all well so search Nvidia
Vulcan and there's a developer one here
and if you go here you'll see that they
have all the stuff that talks about
their samples of code and these are all
the demos you can run they use Vulcan
rendering and Vulcan functionality you
click on more and actually go to it it
basically goes to this Nvidia design
work samples which comes from the Nvidia
company a very cool thing of them to
release so what you really need is you
need the shared sources and the shared
external and then you can run anything
but you need to make sure you clone
these all to the same directory so for
example I open up Fork so I'll just I'll
just go through the first couple and the
rest are all the same so you'll pretty
much get it from there alright so first
of all you want these shared sources and
shared externals so we'll click on
shared sources go over here to find or
clone copy the URL then when we go over
here to for it cuz we get a file clone
and it'll auto paste whatever is on our
clipboard it's ready to go
it's ready to clone shared sources now
this parent folder is important you want
everything to be in the same parent
folder the shared sources and the next
couple we're going to do so I'm actually
gonna change my directories just so I
can redo it so I'm gonna go to Nvidia
I'm just gonna call this Nvidia design
so go into that folder and that's where
I'm gonna save all this stuff shared
sources clone
okay now I want to go to the other one
go to shared external because I could
just assume this out copy that URL file
clone I'll make sure this parent
directory is the same looks like it
changed back video design clone okay and
now we want to go grab a demo that we
would like to run so there are lots
there's all these VK ones let's do this
is a shaded gltf scene so gltf is their
object like their 3d object model type
so this is a sample of a shaded 3d model
so this would be a great one to start
with as you can see by the tags it does
some some basic stuff that you don't
know how to do looks like it gives us
this scene so let's go ahead and do the
same thing we got a cloned copy oh yeah
copy the URL and go to file clone over
on fork put in the same directory and I
gotta go back one just in default
directory so there we go got those two
shared folders we cloned and the one
from this demo you don't even need to
actually need to open this folder after
you clone it you just need to open C
make so run C make guess I could show
you that I basically just typed it in
and ran it that way and you want to
browse to where you saved this scene or
this demo so you go to it just the root
directory of that project and then you
want to do browse build go to the same
place except this is we're going to
basically do your visual studio project
because this is going to turn it into a
visual studio project so we're going to
yeah we'll just hit new folder and we'll
just call this build
so we'll go into that and it's like
folder and then we're gonna go ahead and
hit well you can hit configure or
generate I'm just gonna hit generate
because I want to go ahead and do both
default options there it defaulted to
visual studio 16 which is the 2019
version and let's see what it says now I
always get this there's some warnings
about the Vulcan SDK I don't know if
this is a error with C make or with
Vulcan since they did just update but it
doesn't seem to cause a problem as long
as you have the SDK installed so
everything's good there and you can hit
open project and I'll go ahead and open
it whatever Visual Studio you have by
default now here's their different
solutions over on the right side the
main one we're interested in is this VK
shaded gltf scene it's hard to say and
so we're gonna right-click it and set it
as the startup project and then just
leave everything how they have it and
hit play on this local windows debugger
and it's compiling away and as long as
you have the SDK and the shared and
external sources everything should work
on the first try if you get some error
for your video card that might be a
separate thing
you
as you can see it's just compiling down
that C++ code and here we go
it's taking a moment to load you can see
the memory ramped up as its loading up
that object and shaders and all that
stuff and there it is so you can play
around with this scene and it looks like
they have some stuff with the I am GUI
so you can interact some here and it
says hello Vulcan so there you go
if you want to look at the code you can
expand this project look at the source
files look at the gos files and look at
their comment which looks like they've
got image IMG GUI some Vulcan
implementations of that and yeah you can
have at it checking out their design
code and how they do all that stuff and
I want to say real quickly if you're
having trouble with this open project
like it opens the wrong version or
something you can just go to this folder
I'll just do it real quick you can just
go to this folder and go to build and
open this solution right here
VK shaded gltf scene and you can like
right-click and say open width and you
can pick something if it's opening with
the wrong version of something so just
FYI I know people have been stuck on
that before okay I want to move this out
of the way and we're actually all done
I'll do one more
just for sake of example so let's go
ahead and just back out of this and you
can you can do this with any of these
now any of these will work you just
clone them run C make on it open it and
then switch to the project and run it
let's do I think this one's cool let's
do this one
but there yeah there's everything here
there's threaded there's instanced
rendering I think mesh shaders here
which is some special kind of shader so
I'm gonna copy the directory clone
straighten out this folder hit okay I
can clone that then I'm gonna open up
see make change these to that new
project Michelet change this to a new
output directory we'll do build again
select it okay then we'll just generate
leave it Visual Studio 16 so if you're
on anything else you'll have to adapt
these steps but it will in general be
the same thing looks like it's doing a
download cool must be the project files
so we're going to hit open project
switch to the main scene here set start
a project on VK mesh like add scene hit
play and here it's loading up and there
we go we get a car and we can yeah this
is rendering with Vulcan I know there
are some other tests where you can
switch the rant renderer on the fly to
OpenGL and stuff and see the performance
differences it's pretty cool
basically Vulcan puts more on the video
card and less on the CPU okay so we this
has a clipping plane thing that's really
cool alright well that's it I hope you
enjoyed this video I hope this helps you
get Vulcan up and running and kind of
learn about it some from the Nvidia
standpoint so have at these source files
while they have them available and
yeah it seems like a really great
learning learning tool so I really
wanted to share this with you all and
it's something I'm pretty excited about
I'm gonna be working on it in the first
seeable future well peace out you guys
thanks for checking out a video here on
KOAT Tekken tutorials my name is Matt
don't forget to show some support if you
want to see more videos like this thank
you goodbye
you